[Applaudissements]
on a même un sapin de Noël ah oui je
vois le Michel Sapin voilà
la France a le chic pour transformer ses
défaites en épopée ces échecs en légende
elle a le chic pour construire des
scénarios si invraisemblables que seul
le pays de Molière Descartes ou de
Gaulle est capable d'écrire Hollywood et
Spielberg ne sont rien à côté de ces
bleus et de Deschamps
nous sommes des génies disons-le alors
merci Didier merci Kylian merci Olivier
merci Antoine merci Aurélien merci Hugo
merci Randall merci ce fut un beau
dimanche
elle sera à nous et l'Argentine on vous
pétera la preuve donc 4 ans
qui pleurent il y a des tas de gens qui
pleurent ce soir et on est triste c'est
vrai mais elle a montré du cœur et de
l'unité c'est ça l'image de la France
emails
gâtés parce que quand même il sorte d'un
titre non mais attendez les gamins qu'on
dit qu'on dise 15 ans aujourd'hui ils
ont gagné la Coupe du monde en 2018 moi
j'ai connu moi j'ai connu Glasgow 76
j'ai connu Séville 82 98 c'était énorme
sur le vieux port de Marseille à l'heure
du marché les mots ne sont pas toujours
tendres ils sont mauvais ils sont
mauvais ils sont mauvais et pourquoi il
y a personne là qu'est-ce qui se passe
à la maison et puis moi je suis désolé
j'ai une pensée émue pour c'est une
apoter aux extraordinaires pour le plus
grand joueur de l'histoire sans doute
Lionel Messi ce peuple argentin qui est
un vrai peuple de football il y a pas un
pays au monde où on aime le football
autant qu'en Argentine peut-être au
Brésil non mais non arrêtez c'est pas
c'est pas ça vive le football allez voir
en Argentine et voir tous ces gens dans
les rues voir tous ces jeunes Argentins
dans un pays qui va très mal où il y a
de la misère où il y a du chômage où il
y a ben moi je suis très heureux pour le
peuple argentin lui a carrément perdu
tous ses filtres on aurait comme
meilleur gardien du Mondial le geste de
l'Argentin Emiliano Martinez les
internautes perplexe un subtilage à la
main de Dieu de Maradona sans doute la
gênance continue dans les vestiaires ou
Martinez demande un petit moment de
silence en mémoire de MB
il est franchement barge
[Musique]
canoë
ah le canoë il est barge ah oui c'est
rigolo ça et en première mi-temps on a
lu beaucoup de frustration face à la
domination des Argentins un internaute
qui demande par exemple l'intervention
des lisabeth borne pour arrêter cette
boucherie avec un 49-3 c'est tout un
peuple un pays qui a chaviré dans la
folie
parfois même jusqu'à la crise de la
le football déchaîne les passions et
hier à Buenos Aires personne n'a cherché
à cacher la sienne dans un pays qui vit
le foot comme une religion
[Applaudissements]
le maillot aux trois étoiles flotte aux
balcon la fête de commencer s'éterniser
pourquoi donc dormir quand on peut
profiter d'une telle euphorie
[Applaudissements]
une extase
47 millions d'Argentins
j'y crois pas c'est Diego depuis le ciel
qui nous regarde il fait la fête
un peuple écrasé par la crise économique
s'offre une parenthèse enchantée en Ciel
et Blanc cette folie Argentine est en
fait à la hauteur du besoin de la
population d'oublier ce quotidien très
compliqué avec une crise économique de
grande ampleur ils veulent donc savourer
jusqu'au bout ce moment de bonheur que
leur apporte le football ça me gêne
précisément parce qu'il n'y a que ça
mais qui voulez-vous qu'il est le sport
ça le sport a toujours il y a que le
sport qui réunit les gens sur une pièce
de cornée
si on les réunis 16 sur la qualité d'une
politique l'inflation nous en France on
souffre avec 6% d'inflation l'inflation
en Argentine elle est pas de 6 elle est
de 92% et vous savez comment on combat
l'inflation en relevant les taux
d'intérêt chez nous on les relève à 1 2%
on dit oh là là en Argentine vous
intéresse sont à 75% je voulais venir
vous voir pour vous dire merci et vous
avez fait rêver des Françaises et des
Français qui en ont besoin donc merci à
vous petite devinette quand on vit dans
un pays où les taux d'intérêt sont à 75
%, je vais à la banque j'empreinte
100000 €, vous savez combien il faut que
je rembourse quand j'ai emprunté 100000
€. j'ai du mal à faire le calcul 1
million je dois rembourser 10 fois ce
que j'ai emprunté voilà ce que c'est que
de vivre dans un pays où les taux
d'intérêt sont à fond
belle brochette de pommes de terre c'est
je ne sais pas ce que c'est
mais je pense je salue vous savez moi je
suis tous les messages